Alright you're done.
Let's take a look at my solution.
For the delete method things
are pretty straight forward.
We just called db.delete with the
appropriate table, and the selection,
and the selection arguments.
One thing that I've done is if
the selection is null I set it to one.
This makes delete all rows return
the number of rows deleted.
And that can be useful.
I only notify the content
resolver of a change
if we actually have deleted some rows.
This isn't strictly necessary.
Update looks almost exactly like Delete.
Once again, based upon the URI
we select a different table and
call the update function with
the values in the selection arguments.
And I only notify for a change
we've actually updated some rows.
Alright.
Let's go to test our function.
In test provider you can see we've
uncommented out test delete records
as well as test update location.
Let's run the test to make sure
everything works correctly.
And as you can see everything passes.
We've done everything correct for
updating and
deleting the content provider.